[Music]
on this monday night from washington d.c
just hours left in a relentless campaign
we are going to win four more years
the president's not going to steal this
election last-minute missions by both
presidential candidates to motivate
voters
in key states a racial reckoning in the
race for the white house
i want to have a change in the black
community the impact of the black lives
matter movement on this election
wooing the women of wisconsin will you
please like me
the important demographic that could be
turning on trump
and dreading another shutdown here we go
again manitoba struggles to stop the
spread
of the coronavirus
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are in the american capitol tonight
it is the night before the presidential
election
when millions of american voters decide
who will occupy the white house for the
next four years
and here is a measure of the tension in
washington dc and in some other cities
across this country
buildings are being boarded up as a
precaution in case
there is civil unrest the two
presidential candidates are campaigning
down to the wire in key
states today donald trump in north
carolina wisconsin pennsylvania and
michigan
hosting big rallies with tightly packed
crowds
tomorrow we are going to win the
commonwealth of pennsylvania and we are
going to win
four more years in the white house
is democratic rival joe biden in ohio
and pennsylvania too
hosting socially distant drive-in
rallies
the only thing that can tear america
apart
is america itself and that's exactly
what donald trump's been trying to do
from the very beginning divide america
their aim is the same to energize every
last voter to mark a ballot because
every last vote will count
and early voting in this election has
surpassed all records
global national has the country covered
tonight sarah mcdonald is reporting from
portland oregon
heather urix west is in minneapolis jeff
semple is in kenosha wisconsin tonight
mike armstrong is in philadelphia for us
and jackson proskow and farah nasser are
here with me
in washington we begin our coverage with
jackson
and the final pitches being made in
battleground states
on the eve of the election ohio one more
day joe biden and donald trump focused
on the few states that could tip the
scales
we're going to win the whole thing state
by state fights appear much closer than
national polls suggest
it's time for donald trump to pack his
bags and go
home time to sway voters is running out
with nearly 100 million early votes
already cast
trump has struggled to form a closing
argument
the president now says he might fire the
top pandemic expert in the u.s dr
anthony fauci
even as the coronavirus rages let me
wait till
a little bit after the election elect me
and i'm going to hire
dr fauci on this final day trump hit
four states ending in michigan where he
wrapped his 2016 campaign
biden focused heavily on ohio and
battleground pennsylvania
where trump too paid a visit to biden's
hometown of scranton
and where election officials are pushing
back on the president's claims
that a winner must be decided on tuesday
i think it's a terrible thing
when states are allowed to tabulate
ballots
for a long period of time after the
election is over the state warns it
could take until friday to count
millions of mail-in ballots
same story in michigan and ohio where
officials are bracing for a long
slow count election night is important
it's when
people stop casting ballots but it's
certainly not when the elections
process is over
and the last minute push for votes is
being met by last-minute wrangling in
the courts late this afternoon a judge
in texas threw out a challenge by
republicans that would have disqualified
more than 100 thousand votes cast at
drive-in voting sites
in nevada a judge tossed out a
republican challenge to stop the early
voting count
donna this is likely to continue in
state after state as we wait on those
election results
and democrats have 4 000 lawyers on
standby just in the state of florida
lawyers are going to be busy and jackson
the democrats are
looking for not just a win but a big
convincing win why is that so important
for them it really is all about avoiding
all the drama all those worst case
scenarios that we keep talking about
time and time again if they can get a
clear convincing win
it removes that sort of tenuous period
while we're waiting on a final count
and really removes the need for lawyers
and recounts and all that mess
we can only hope there won't be all a
mess after the election we'll see
tomorrow night jackson prosco thank you
the pandemic and its impact on health
and the economy has loomed over the
whole campaign
and like so many issues in america it
has divided voters
we want to play you a clip of the
republican lieutenant governor of idaho
she's part of a group that believes
the right to personal freedom trumps the
restrictions imposed
to limit the spread of the coronavirus
we
recognize that all of us are by nature
free
and equal and have certain inalienable
rights
among which are enjoying and defending
life and liberty
acquiring possessing and protecting
property
and pursuing happiness and securing
safety
and yes that was a gun and a bible she
was holding
donald trump is holding one of his last
rallies tonight in kenosha wisconsin
that city made headlines in august when
the police repeatedly shot jacob blake a
black man
in the back at close range that led to
waves of protests in the county trump
won by just 255 votes in 2016.
jeff semple is reporting from kenosha
tonight
residents of kenosha wisconsin are just
beginning to rebuild
now more than two months since their
city was scorched
protests over the police shooting of
jacob blake destroyed dozens of
businesses
this resident says she was scared to
step outside what did kenosha ever do to
anybody
anybody so it was bad president trump
deployed the national guard and kenosha
became the backdrop for his law and
order
campaign you wouldn't have a kenosha if
there was an
interrupt with all of its burned and
boarded up buildings you might think
kenosha and wisconsin would be
the most receptive audience for trump's
law and order message
but voters here particularly in the
suburbs are more concerned
with another crisis the biggest issue
right now to me
is colvin wisconsin has fast become a
pandemic hot spot
nearly a third of its tests last week
were positive
my mom's name was ann peerless jean
peroles strauss's mother caught kovid 19
and last week she died we were not able
to be with her
so something has to change in our
country
polls suggest the pandemic has become
the most important
issue here in the campaign and it
matters most
to women white suburban women have
changed
emily siegrist is running for the
democrats in this suburban riding
suburban women like herself helped to
elect trump in 2016
but the president has downplayed the
pandemic and wisconsin's republican
lawmakers
have thwarted attempts to mandate masks
and
lockdowns people are dying we need to
just step aside and say like it's not
about being a republican or a democrat
it's just about being a human
this suburban swing voter helped to
launch a wisconsin women for biden
facebook page that's grown to more than
12 thousand members
women are sick of the vitriol
and are very afraid of losing
health care for their children for their
families women
whether they're urban suburban or rural
are less supportive of the president his
latest poll
finds biden up five points in wisconsin
and 30 points ahead with women
the same group that gave trump the keys
to the white house may be the ones
to evict him jeff temple global news
kenosha
three things make this election more
tense than most the deep political
divide that surge in kovid 19 cases jeff
mentioned and the social unrest
that was sparked after the killing of
george floyd in minneapolis minnesota
his death at the hands of police fired
up the black lives matter movement all
over the world
and it is mobilizing many voters in this
election heather urix west is in the
city
where george floyd lived
h.p rogers has only been a photographer
for six months
after the death of george floyd here in
may he was inspired to capture
everything that happened next after
taking that photo my eyes were burning
my nose was burning
and to see people stand in that for as
long as they did
just just like shows the amount of
passion and dedication people have for
what they're out here for
he believes that passion and dedication
will now be carried to the polls
four years ago voter turnout among
african americans dropped significantly
right across the country
this time around that's expected to
change particularly here
in minnesota this is a an election of a
lifetime you know we hear that cliche
abandoned about in every election but
this is
in my 42 years of life the most
important that i think i'll ever be a
part of
jamar nelson has spent months
campaigning for the democrats
he says he's excited to cast his ballot
in person tuesday
and this year he'll have his son by his
side
jamar junior turns 18 monday right
before
election day i want to have a change in
a black community so everything could be
different and not everything would be
the same anymore
but with excitement comes anxiety four
years ago lewis hunter's cousin philando
castile was fatally shot by a police
officer
during a traffic stop in saint paul the
restaurant owner plans to vote for joe
biden
but worries for his city should the
election go the other way
i don't know i can't even imagine
because it's scary i'm hoping for peace
even if it happens back in the
neighborhood where george floyd died
butchie austin sees things differently i
really
believe what happened here in may is
it was a moral issue it really had
nothing to do
with your partisan alignment does he
plan to vote
absolutely but he says he knows the
struggle for racial justice will
continue
long after election day heather urex
west global news
minneapolis there is unease about what
could happen in the hours and days after
the election especially if president
trump prematurely claims victory before
a result is clear
oregon's governor has put the national
guard on standby in portland
there were mass demonstrations and riots
there when trump won in 2016
and it's been a flash point this year in
response to racial injustice
global's sarah mcdonald is in portland
tonight
as the world watched the mayhem
unfolding on the streets of portland
oregonians on the ground had no choice
but to be consumed by it
i've lived in different corners of the
country and the racism here is so
insidious but it is definitely
everywhere for ty carpenter who heads
the group don't shoot portland
and the city itself the violent protests
were unprecedented
but the racial injustice that galvanized
citizens
is nothing new the past couple years of
fear mongering and
racial tensions building it's been even
worse in recent weeks you know there's a
lot of hate crimes that happen here in
portland oregon
there's a very strong presence of far
right extremists
the movement also inspired allies like
baker kerry padian to take action
and take heat for it taking a public
stance in support of demonstrators
demands to defund the police
the response from critics was swift and
fierce
obviously it hit a sore point and that
was
that was important to us to sort of keep
going but black americans like carl
jefferson
say the protests don't speak for him i
believe that things should be done in a
more
orderly fashion and it affected me in a
way that it's
disheartening that i didn't know my
country would delve to this level
marcus gabriel jr lives and works in red
swinging suburbia
it's really like brought to light like
certain people's opinions and feelings
that i like
didn't realize that they had once the
ballots are cast and the polls are
closed
partisanship is expected to boil over in
portland once again
with state officials taking a preemptive
strike on monday
to simmer growing tensions we know that
there are some people who might want to
use peaceful election night protests
to promote violence and property
destruction
with clashes expected in some capacity
even law enforcement officials are
growing uneasy
one officer based in portland told us
off camera he fears for his safety
and that of his family in the current
political climate
donna all right sarah mcdonald in
portland oregon thanks
we have breaking news from vienna
austria a manhunt is underway after what
the austrian chancellor calls a
repulsive
terror attack
at least one person is dead several more
wounded some of them seriously
police say several attackers armed with
rifles launched the assault in six
different locations they say it started
at the city's main synagogue
one suspect has been shot and killed and
a large part of vienna has been cordoned
off by the police
people told to stay inside while police
search for suspects
a warning from manitoba's premier
tonight
coming up what he is considering to try
to curb covet 19.
there is a surge in covid19 cases in
canada bc has set
new records for covet 19 case numbers
over the past three days
379 just in the past day almost
all are linked to social gatherings in
private homes in manitoba the winnipeg
region is in code red now new
restrictions in place there there's no
question
these rules harm businesses and as
abigail beeman reports
getting the balance right is not easy
here we go again in red zoned winnipeg
restaurants can now only offer takeout
and delivery
we don't have any money to keep on doing
this sandy doyle is worried blondie's
burgers and other restaurants like hers
won't survive a second lockdown
we're panicking we're angry we're
frustrated
like we're just at our wit's end
manitoba's premier now asking people to
cut
contacts by a whopping 75 percent brian
pallister is considering a curfew
and promising tougher enforcement
measures we had
several hundred calls from great
manitobans alerting us to situations
principally group gatherings
last week we had three tickets given out
that's not acceptable
alberta's premier says data doesn't
support restaurant closures but jason
kenney has a message for partiers
knock it off one of the biggest areas of
spread is coming from that kind of
private socializing
in ontario cases dipped just below a
thousand for the second day in a row
as premier doug ford committed to four
hours of care a day for people living in
long-term care
by 2025. this is a monumental step
forward it will mean hiring thousands
and thousands of new support staff
and this historic investment will make
ontario the first jurisdiction
in canada to commit the four hours of
care
a move advocates have long been calling
for as the elderly remain at risk
in the second wave abigail beeman global
news
ottawa racism
in america ahead how it's motivating
voters in this election
welcome back there's no question the us
is facing a stark choice in this
election
deciding who to vote for is always
driven in part by what's affecting
individual voters lives
and in this election for many americans
issues of race are top of mind
as far as nasser explains
the killing of george floyd in may
unleashed a wave of anger and resentment
about the treatment of african americans
and other people of color
at the hands of police and about a
president who is being
at best tone deaf on these issues
stand back and stand by and at worst has
openly encouraged white supremacist
groups
people say donald trump is a president
unlike any other and that's true
but trump is not an aberration of
history rather he is a product of
american history
and of a democracy that has become more
partisan and more polarized with each
passing year
republicans and democrats have always
had different views but the gap between
them
has never been as wide as it is now this
is the memorial to republican president
dwight d eisenhower in the 50s he had an
88 approval rating among party faithful
remarkably nearly half of all democrats
approved of him as well
now you could chalk that up to the fact
that the economy was booming in the
post-war era
but then take a look at this in 1956
eisenhower got almost 40 percent of the
african-american vote
but by the 1960s following the passage
of the civil rights act by democrat
lyndon johnson
that supported plummeted to just 6
percent
under nixon republicans used the
so-called southern strategy
veiled racist messaging to attract
disgruntled white voters in the south
the seeds of trumpism were planted
decades ago
and it's over race where the divisions
are the most clear
before 1964 african-american voters were
distributed among the two parties
but over time a gap developed as
non-white voters steadily and
dramatically
shifted to the democratic party today
those divisions are most striking in the
rust belt areas to the north where
white rural voters some of them lifelong
democrats
came out in droves in 2016 and gave
president
trump the white house and that's why
wisconsin
michigan and pennsylvania will be key
battlegrounds this election
foreign asser global news washington
up next from 2016 to 2020 how the last
four years
influenced how these americans will vote
we're back from washington after a break
welcome back to washington our reporter
mike armstrong has been on the road in
the u.s for a couple of weeks now
observing all the public health
restrictions of course
and he's talked to all kinds of people
including some he met while covering the
2016 campaign
mike wanted to find out if the last four
years have changed
how they feel today
we found this house the same way we
found it four years ago
literally by accident you've got the
signs up again
we met chris kinney just a few days
before the last presidential election he
came out while we were taking shots of
his house in lancaster pennsylvania
and told us back then he'd been inspired
by donald trump to put the signs up
something he'd never done before nope
never before
this is different this election yes it's
very different four years ago
you said you had never had a sign out in
front of your house
you've got the signs back because i
support trump
with all my heart this is a big crowd
not a lot has changed in kinney's
opinion except perhaps when it comes to
the media
he's not a big fan of people in our
profession and the way
trump's being treated totally unfair
unjustified
i haven't watched cnn or msnbc since the
last election
and i won't because it's depressing you
can't get the real news
now catching up with diane childress was
a little tougher this was the morning
after the 2016 election
in new freedom pennsylvania she was with
friends in a restaurant
happy happy happy yeah it's been four
years since i saw you the last time yeah
i remember it very well
are you still voting the same way yes
how come
put this way there's never been any
better than anybody better than trump as
far as i'm concerned
over the course of the last four years
there have been some
scandals or things that you could
criticize donald trump for oh yeah
well you tell me one president could not
be criticized and i'll say
not going to happen i mean but some of
them are a little over the top
paying off porn stars but is it really
true
is all that really true i don't believe
all of it i really don't
no my vote has not changed since the
last time around over the course of the
last few weeks we've interviewed or just
spoken to
hundreds of americans across five states
and yet somehow
i don't believe we've met a single
person who's told us they've changed
their vote since the last election
they may be out there we just haven't
met any it's
hard not to conclude this isn't just a
divided country
but one where both sides are absolutely
entrenched
in how they see things mike armstrong
global news
philadelphia
pretty fascinating and that is global
national for this monday i'm donna
friesen we'll have live coverage of the
us election tomorrow starting at 7 pm
eastern 4 p.m pacific
on the global tv app amazon prime video
on our website globalnews.ca and on our
youtube channel so no excuses
that is it for us from washington
tonight we'll see you here again
tomorrow
thanks for watching bye